Robert Downey Jr. has been acting forever.
From a very young age he’s had parts in
his father, Robert Downey Sr.’s movies.
Born to a director and an actress, he seemed
destined for a career in showbiz.
And what a career it’s been.
Beginning with his dad’s movie Pound in
1970, he made his big screen debut as a puppy.
And from there, little by little, his career
started to take off.
Robert Downey Jr. has held a few different
positions in Hollywood, and has gone from
one of the lowest to highest paid actors of
all time.
This is The Amazing Evolution of Robert Downey
Jr. in Movies.
Venturing outside of his father’s films,
Downey Jr. was cast as cool guy Ian in the
1985 classic Weird Science.
The actor was also a part of the cat of Saturday
Night Live for a while before signing up to
play Julian - the coke-addicted teenager from
1987’s Less Than Zero.
The movie was based on the Brett Easton Ellis
novel of the same name, and gave him the opportunity
to flex his dramatic chops.
Suddenly people were saying “holy shit,
this kid can act.”
Good thing, too.
Because he was on his way to working with
one of the most in-demand actors of the time.
Someone who would turn out to be a very important
ally down the road.
Working with Mel Gibson on 1990’s Air America,
the two actors became fast friends.
As Billy, Downey played a young pilot who
loses his license during the Vietnam War era.
As a result, his job opportunities are minimal.
So when he’s recruited to fly delivery planes
in Laos, he accepts.
The only downside is that his peers and bosses
are actually all dangerous criminals.
And what started as a neat employment opportunity
quickly erodes into a life-threatening situation.
As a director, Richard Attenborough told the
stories of important historical figures.
Winston Churchill, Mahatma Gandhi, and Ernest
Hemingway to name a few.
But it was when he sought to tell the story
of comedy legend Charlie Chaplin that he crossed
paths with Robert Downey Jr.
The role required versatility; someone who
could nail Chaplin’s comedic timing as well
as his tortured soul.
Audiences were taken aback by what the actor
could do, and were in awe of the physical
resemblance between the two men.
The academy took notice, too.
And come award season, his performance earned
him a nomination in the Best Actor category.
Over the decade that followed his Oscar nom,
the actor went through struggles in his personal
life.
Some of them got him in trouble with Hollywood,
and as a result his reputation came under
fire.
After all the negative press, filmmakers were
reluctant to cast Downey Jr.
But if you take a look at his IMDB page, it
appears as though he never stopped working,
even if there is a noticeable difference in
the quality of his characters.
In 2003, a good word from old friend Mel Gibson
went a long way.
In talking with the team behind The Singing
Detective, Gibson suggested they also cast
RDJ, and vouched for his friend in a big way.
Which some people argue was the turning point
of his whole career.
Cited among lifelong fans as their favorite
RDJ performance, Kiss Kiss Bang Bang was the
birthplace of a brand new kind of sarcastic
wiseass.
And if you haven’t seen it, you really should.
Directed by Shane Black and co-starring Val
Kilmer, the movie is a twisting murder mystery
with some of the most epic and witty exchanges
of all time.
And if you can keep up with the back and forth,
you’ll probably agree.
The 2005 comedy seemed to soften audiences
up a little, and the actor’s career picked
up steam and hasn’t stopped since.
In his work as Harry Lockhart, RDJ proved
that he could handle the kind of dialogue
that requires a sharp tongue.
Good thing, too.
Because perfectly timed rants happen to be
the main export of the next big character
heading his way.
Without a question, the actor is a household
name because of his work as Tony Stark a.k.a
Iron Man.
The relatively niche character is now a veritable
worldwide phenomenon, and audiences will flood
the theatre every single time the Avenger
appears on the big screen.
That’s good news for everyone.
Fans get more of what they want, the studio
gets to expand the cinematic universe, and
the actor gets to keep playing a character
he clearly loves.
It’s a good thing that playing Stark has
been such a positive experience so far, since
Iron Man still has a few more appearances
to make.
Clearly, Robert Downey Jr. is a man of many
talents.
His characters are layered and complex; always
interesting.
But the amount of layers belonging to Kirk
Lazarus of Tropic Thunder is over-the-top.
And that’s exactly the point.
The dude playin’ the dude disguised as another
dude is an Oscar-winning Australian method
actor who gets cast as a soldier and then
turns into a soldier for real…
You know what?
It’s complicated.
Just do yourself a favor and watch the movie.
By 2009, RDJ had experience playing characters
that had first become famous in books.
And since the stories of Sherlock Holmes have
been corrupted so many times, we can’t blame
anyone who was skeptical when they first heard
about the Guy Ritchie reboot.
With Jude Law playing the Watson to his Holmes,
Downey blew viewers away with his take on
the titular detective.
And even won a Golden Globe for it.
The movie was incredibly successful, and so
was it’s sequel.
Recently it was announced that the franchise
is getting a third installment.
And we can’t wait.
In between saving the world and being a dad,
the actor has also founded a production company,
fittingly named Team Downey.
Along with his wife Susan, they recently produced
a film called The Judge in 2014.
And, because he CLEARLY didn’t already have
enough on his plate, he starred in it too.
What do you think of our video?
Did we miss any other interesting roles Robert
Downey Jr’s career?
Tell us about them in the comments section,
and subscribe to our YouTube channel for more
videos like this one.